[Musique]
dans ce centre d'appels d'urgence de
l'oise les pompiers tentent de gérer la
crise
car hier soir si vous composiez le 18
vous aviez de grandes chances de ne pas
pouvoir les joindre plusieurs réunions
de crise sont organisées par les
autorités dans la soirée des numéros
temporaires sont mises en place dans
chaque département
mais les conséquences sur les
interventions d'urgence sont dramatiques
notamment dans le morbihan où un patient
de 63 ans n'a pu être secourus à temps
dysfonctionnements que l'on peut
qualifier de grave et d'inacceptable on
pouvait obtenir quelqu'un au téléphone
mais il fallait appeler de très
nombreuses fois évidemment dans les cas
d'urgence la pose des problèmes que
chacun comprenne mes premiers mots sont
pour présenter les excuses d'orange aux
personnes qui auraient été victimes de
ce dysfonctionnement
mais aussi à tous nos partenaires pour
ses numéros d'urgence je pense aux
pompiers au samu aux hôpitaux et
d'ailleurs de saluer aussi la réactivité
dont ils ont fait preuve
évidemment nous allons faire un retour
d'expérience de tout ce qui s'est passé
de exigé des explications de la part de
l'opérateur téléphonique
nous évoquons 3d c'est trois quatre
décès enregistrés sur le territoire
national à l'heure à laquelle nous nous
parlons je ne peux pas dire si cette
exhaustif évidemment elle contrevient à
la loi écocide qu'elle fait voter en se
rendant coupable de destruction d'un
patrimoine naturel d' atteinte à la
biodiversité d'artificialisation des
sols et de soutien aux énergies fossiles
en train de regarder faire le bilan il
ya eu très vite des numéros à 10
chiffres qui ont été mises à disposition
et on a rebasculé les numéros sur les
départements où ça tenait donc c'est
trop tôt pour faire un bilan mais
évidemment on est très préoccupé vous en
avez donné un exemple parfait on est
dans une hystérisation du débat sur les
éoliennes et sur les énergies
renouvelables et sur la transition
énergétique qui ne sert pas en fait
notre avenir et qui ne sert pas y
compris la cause qui est défendu par
ceux qui défendent notre patrimoine dont
je fais partie c'est mon petit zemmour
battant jeu les écrabouiller un peu sûr
que je parle pas de lui donc le battant
je pense à
ouais je passe à marine le pen et c'est
des choses bizarres qui se dit sur moi
alors on a déterré par exemple des
techniques de des terres et des formes
et des tournées des gueules toi c'est
bizarre
ouais ouais puisque monsieur muselier
veut porter plainte contre moi qu'il le
fasse à ce que vous l'avez accusé
d'avoir recruté davantage dans son
service de communication que justement
dans les transports oui au bout d'un
moment dans ses critiques j'ai porté
plainte sont désormais nanti arlette de
disséminer des forces nouvelles il y
avait 64 personnes à la communication
quand je suis arrivé sous verre de
monsieur z nous sommes aujourd'hui 61 au
gala moins de 3 les chiffres que je
donne ce sont les chiffres de la chambre
régionale des comptes au 31 décembre il
y avait l'équivalent de 212 emplois
temps plein au cabinet de 116,8 il y
avait 2 178 personnes
alors je vous en dirai at il rappelé
c'est entouré par ses gardes du corps
que milla arrivent au tribunal
sans un mot elle rentre dans la salle
d'audience me l'a vit sous protection
policière depuis ces publications
polémique sur l'islam cette jeune fille
de 18 ans subi insultes et menaces sur
les réseaux sociaux
treize personnes soupçonnées d'avoir
participé à ce cyber harcèlement sont
jugés aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui vous avez une jeune
française qui doit se cacher dans son
pays parce que une horde de haineux une
horde de communautariste a décrété
qu'elle n'avait pas le droit de
critiquer une religion que l'on soit
jeune adolescent en adulte à partir du
moment où on commet un crime sur
internet
on peut être recherchée on peut être
retrouvés et on peut être jugé devant un
tribunal
c'est pour ça qu'on est là aujourd'hui
mais j'ai des enfants voient ce que j'ai
à dire non plus pour longtemps